[Music]
Charlotte I would like to endorse you to
be the next president of the United
States oh my god you've been a great
Secretary of State which state again all
of them I kind of know her it's like
kind of known a mermaid do you tell
people that you're poison remember who I
am
secretary field would like to speak with
you with me I can't shake this feeling
that we know each other we do we do
picture me I guess maybe like 20 years
younger but like this Barsky
yeah what are you doing these days I'm a
journalist you're a great writer but
sometimes you're a little too much I'm
the perfect right portion it's really
nice to see you again
okay you boys you may just call me a
cracker what is the relationship exactly
it's to babysit for them you babysat for
him
Wow time has not been kind I need some
writers to punch up my speeches that's
writing is really good and he knows me
oh I feel so scared you know what right
better for you I should kind of get to
know you better and if you have a minute
I actually have seven seven minutes in
heaven
what is your pretty red book as a kid
The Velveteen Rabbit parasol must have
been loved by rocks most embarrassing
moment I don't know
what's your favorite sexual position
normal pacing normal question what's
your favorite sexual position
don't be gross right do a date I mean
who wants to follow me around the world
and hope I have five minutes to be
affectionate yeah we actually did almost
die we need to move you Thank You agent
M it's pretty woman but she's Richard
Gere and you're Julia Roberts honestly
this is a bit of the best few weeks of
my entire life
we a thousand constituents how they
would feel if Kate Middleton say we're
going with us we're to start dating
Danny DeVito pretty negative reaction
[Music]
oh but how does that work with you to
you like she like date ah yeah I date
generally you know with people who have
similar lifestyles to me people who
travel a lot it's hard to keep those
things alive I'm I mean who wants to
follow me around the world and hope I
have five minutes to be affectionate
yeah and honestly guys don't really want
to date women who are more powerful than
them they think they do but it's a
picture blur dicks traveler is my
favorite Batman villain though so you
gonna ask why I'm still single
no I get it yeah it adds up it's pretty
woman you're Julia Roberts and Richard
Gere's about to come pick you up so I
look okay do I look funny
why are you these pockets here why am I
wearing these stupid pants they're too
tapered you can't think like this you
have to be positive mr. Claire ski
wish me luck Lilly he's gonna need luck
man she said it was okay luck is for
losers
we've got destiny on your side good Fred
you body body doesn't mean anything
Fred put the seatbelt on take care of my
friend all right I look normal
you look cool I love you that was her
life
everybody this is my best friend he just
lost his job today
all right he's at rock bottom it's not
that but I'm gonna make him feel better
I'm going off grit till tomorrow matter
of fact everybody's got the day off
everybody's got the damn y'all got the
day off
everybody go home I'm so appreciative of
all you guys is hard work I love every
single one of you except you Ted bagel
Friday is for everybody tad you don't
think we know you taking the bagels
Zander yeah I need two cans of the
peplum mousse Lacroix I need that fill
with Johnny Walker Blue and CBD oil do
you want one
[Music]
Hey
I had some jokes uh uh I was gonna run
by you maybe if you have a second what
do you what do you looking at Jesus why
would you just barge in here while I'm
sleeping
you were sleeping yes I was my
chronomaly that's what you call that
yes sorry I didn't I didn't realize you
were sleeping you were standing and your
eyes were open do you need something
I have some jokes that I wrote I was
gonna run by you if you have a second
yeah that was actually a really good nap
great seemed very restful I've been a
huge Seth Rogen fan great to hear really
only wanted to make the movie with her
and it took us like seven years to get
successful enough to get Charlize Theron
in our movie I'm usually in movies where
a lot of people die I think this could
be fun good you don't feel it
Oh more what if we made the kind of
movie I grew up watching that is
actually romantic and actually funny hey
give a second
what are you why would you just barge in
here while I'm sleeping you were
sleeping
yes I was micro Natalie that's what you
call that it felt like we could go and
explore a real relationship sparks fly
or do they
[Music]